[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein brot rezept denn wir
werden ein trocken brot backen morath
hedge fonds schon erkannt anhand der
maserung ganz ehrlich nein nein da würde
ich nicht mal erkennen das ist brot ist
egal das ist eine andere sache rockend
wort hat nämlich immer diese typische
maserung das reißt richtig schön ein
und ich finde es jetzt so richtig schön
rustikal aus vor allem hat einen ganz
tollen und kräftigen geschmack und ja
und ich habe das ganze aus sorgen
körnern gemacht das heißt es kaum selbst
gemahlen und den teig gestern angesetzt
und daraus gesetzt dieses brot
entstanden und ich finds echt erhöht da
kann ich wahrscheinlich kaum erwarten
das produkt probieren sieht aus wie ich
war geschockt schreibt oder bedienungs
streifen und haben auch übergewichtige
war da gerade
[Gelächter]
ok damit den rissen ja oder sommer zum
teil
ok ich hab' den teig wie gesagt gestern
angesetzt das ganze selbst gemahlen ihr
könnt natürlich auch gekauftes
roggenmehl nehmen aber selbst gemalt ist
wirklich viel besser
vor allem ist der geschmack intensiver
unter nährstoffen und enthalten
und bevor tim moore an woche mccourts
redet zeige ich euch jetzt mal die
zutaten und zeige was ihr beim backen
beachten ist für das roggenbrot brauche
ich 575 kam rocken körner
die werde ich zum mehl mahlen und davon
brauche ich 175 gramm für den vorteig
plus 175 gramm hefe wasser und für das
frühstück brauche ich 40 gramm vom
rocken
eine gramm salz und 60 gramm wasser
zuerst nämlich jetzt die rocken körner
und gehe es jetzt in die getreidemühle
und da passen ungefähr 500 gramm reiner
aber das kriege ich auch so und ich
werde jetzt das zu rocken vollkornmehl
setzt malen ist einfach viel viel
aromatischer als m ist wirklich mal
ausprobieren
die mühle habe ich jetzt auf ganz fein
gestellt jetzt werde ich einfach die
maschine auf stufe 10 stellen und kann
in der zwischenzeit ein bisschen was
anderes machen das dauerte zwei tage
nutzen
das mehl ist jetzt erst mal fertig
abschütteln und die schüssel raus jetzt
nämlich 40 gramm davon für das frühstück
und die habe ich jetzt bereits auch
schon wasser aufkochen lassen also die
60 gramm funk gerade eben da kommt jetzt
noch das salz betreiben und das wasser
und jetzt kann ich das hier verrühren
und dann das glas verschließen und über
nacht stehen lassen und das frühstück
wird gemacht weil nämlich ansonsten des
rock'n prozess schnell austrocknet und
vor allem aber auch damit man das
protein formen kann und es auch wirklich
in form bleibt
das werde jetzt hier verschlossen dann
stelle ich es kurz zur seite kann jetzt
hier von de-mail noch mal was abwiegen
und 275 kommen denn das wird jetzt der
sauerteig das ganze wird dann mit dem
hefe wasser angesetzt also mit der hefe
dich selbst hergestellt habe
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt aus hefe wasser drauf und
auch die zutaten werden jetzt gut
verbunden
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier beides angesetzt und
das kann ich jetzt über nacht stehen
lassen für 15 bis 18 stunden
vor allem finde ich es auch richtig
hübsch in den gläschen sieht fast aus
wie in den küchen dekoration was aber
auch den vorteil hat mit dem schildchen
hier vorne ich kann auch aufschreiben
wann ich das brot weiterverarbeitet das
heißt wann ich den teig weiter benutzen
muss falls ihr vielleicht auch mal ein
zwei drei rezepte gleichzeitig macht
dann wisst ihr immer ganz genau das ist
jetzt für das angebot und das muss ich
dann zum beispiel morgen um 14 uhr
weiter verarbeiten also lass ich es bei
raumtemperatur stehen und dann geht's
morgen mit dem brot weiter jetzt am
nächsten tag sieht das ganze so aus sie
habe ich den rock'n sauerteig und das
rocken brüste und jetzt werde ich den
teig zusammenzufügen
das heißt ich sage ich hier fordern noch
was ich außerdem benötige ich habe
zitiert den fertigen sauerteig hier ist
das frühstück das übrige mehr sind 365
gramm roggenmehl was ich gestern
gemahlen habe 240 gramm wasser und 11,1
jetzt nämlich beide teige dh den
sauerteig und das bruchstück berichtet
mg pro stück und die kommen jetzt in der
küchenmaschine ihr könnt den teig aber
auch gerne mit der hand verkneten
ich mach das jetzt so weil einfach noch
ein bisschen mehl dazu kommt
aber wie gesagt mit der hand es auch
super einfach denn da teig muss gar
nicht lange knetet werden sondern nur so
lange bis alles sich gut verbunden hat
den rest hat ihr nämlich das dauert
schon erledigt
den bekommen wir ein leckeres brot ist
bestückt mit bisschen fester jetzt
verbinde ich erstmal die zwei zutaten
am anfang ist das kneten ein bisschen
schwierig weil das frühstück einfach so
fest ist dann geht jetzt einfach ein
bisschen mehr dazu dann geht es ein
bisschen einfacher
und sobald ihr merkt die das frühstück
hat sich gut mit dem sauerteig verbunden
könnt ihr die restlichen zutaten einfach
zu fügen und den zeigt so lange kneten
bis alle seine homogene masse ist also
bis sich alles gut verbunden hat
[Musik]
die tat sich der teig gut verbunden und
ist nämlich die schüssel heraus schaut
einfach noch mal nach ob irgendwo noch
mehr reste sind und gerade sitzt alles
zu einem klumpen nach unten
und jetzt denke ich den tag ab und lass
ihn bei raumtemperatur etwa zwei stunden
stehen also echt super einfach
jetzt ist der rock'n teig so weit
und jetzt habe ich meine arbeitsfläche
bereits gewählt und gebt ihn jetzt da
drauf und ich sehe das auch schön
kompakt
jetzt kann ich ihnen zu einer kugel
formen
[Musik]
zum aufgehen nehme ich jetzt ein gelb
köpfchen die werden nicht mit gebacken
sondern darin darf das boot einfach nur
aufgehen bekommt eine schöne form und
später werde ich dann ohne diese form
backen
damit der teig jetzt hier nicht dran
geht muss man das jetzt aus schrauben
aus bestäuben aus bestäuben wir sagen
bestäuben egal ich bleib bestäuben und
darf mit dafür nämlich jetzt keinen mehr
sondern ich nehme es reis mehl das ist
glutenfrei das habe ich jetzt auch mit
der getreidemühle gemacht jetzt ist hier
einfach so drüber 7
denn so verhindere ich dass der teig
später einfach dran kleben dann die
kugel hinein am besten mit der nach oben
denn ich will ja auch später die schöne
oberfläche haben und jetzt werde ich das
ganze abdecken und für eine stunde ruhen
lassen
jetzt ist der rock'n teig so weit das
ist echt wurden das schön aus und ich
habe jetzt bereits den ofen schon
vorgeheizt auf 240 grad ober unterhitze
und ich habe auch schon einen
gusseisernen topf drin
guck mal kurz rein der wird jetzt
nämlich gerade aufgewärmt und darin wird
gleich das brot gebacken um das brot
jetzt aber da rein zu bekommen muss ich
es aus dieser form raus stürzen und
damit ich mir gleich die hände nicht
verbrenne zum reinlegen nehme ich jetzt
ein backpapier das halte ich kurz daten
ich habe jetzt ein bisschen größer
gedruckt
jetzt halte ich das in der mitte und
halte es noch einmal und jetzt nehme ich
die offenen seiten hier also nicht die
geschlossenen seite die brauche ich noch
gibt es jetzt hier dran geschlossene
seite genau mittig über tief backform
und jetzt kann ich hier grad oder kleine
sec ausschneiden
dann kann ich das nämlich gleich zu
entfalten benutzen
das heißt ich legte es jetzt hier drauf
ich kann es jetzt auf backpapier stürzen
mit hilfe eines torten rettungs und
jetzt hole ich kurz den topf aus dem
ofen und dann kann ich es brot
hineinlegen electric nehmen und jetzt
ganz vorsichtig der truppe ist sehr heiß
und jetzt kann ich mithilfe des papiers
das brot ganz aufgegeben jetzt wieder
die handschuhe dann den deckel drauf und
so kann das wurde jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 240 grad ober
unterhitze mit deckel für 20 minuten
rein dann nehme ich den deckel weg und
baktus boot noch mal 15 bis 20 minuten
und jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht
warum backe ich das brot in einem
gusseisernen topf ihr habt vielleicht
schon mal den begriff gehört mit
schwarzem backen
das heißt mit seinem dampf stoß viele
machen das so dass er den wassereintritt
backofen rein kippen was von nachteil
ist wenn man sehr kalkhaltiges wasser
hat denn dann hat man die ganzen übel
und kalt checken im backofen und der
gusseiserner dufter ersetzt ist backen
mit schwarzem das heißt das wasser was
in dem brot steckt das steigt jetzt nach
oben entweicht aus dem brot und dann
verfängt ist der deckel wieder auf man
geht das wasser praktisch wieder zurück
und so packen wir jetzt das brot im
dampf 20 minuten mit deckel und 15 bis
20 minuten ohne deckel 20 minuten sind
vorbei das heißt ich kann jetzt den
deckel entfernen
jetzt schauen wir mal zusammen rein
[Musik]
jetzt ist das brot fertig jetzt gucken
wir mal gemeinsam alles so schön
geworden
guckt euch das brot mal richtig toll
jetzt hole ich es aus dem ofen umstellt
jetzt hier ab und lasse abkühlen bevor
wir es dann probieren kann
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt das fertige brot aus und
hier seht ihr übrigens das wird jetzt
ein bisschen gelb aus das ist einfach
dabei zum titel krise und lehrreich
waren bisschen drin
das kann ich jetzt habe ich so wegnehmen
und dann sieht man das gar nicht mehr
und hier habe ich die form nur mit mehl
bestreut so ich würde sagen das behalten
wir fürs foto und das schneiden oder
keine antwort ist auch eine andere liga
ist ein echtes stück oder noch einmal
egal gibt mir einfach nur zuschauen wie
man die wahrheit sagen das ist heute
schon das vierte team richtig essen muss
ja eigentlich schon vorüber alles das
ist ja der fünfte brot und wenn es so
weitergeht dann gegen eine
glutenunverträglichkeit also das größte
riecht sehr sehr lecker und ich habe es
auch schon probiert weil ich ich würde
es lieben beispiel zweiten tag eine gut
gehende jeden tag
ich muss zugeben heute war einfach unser
brot backt tag ich habe gestern einfach
alle tage angesetzt und jetzt haben wir
halt sechs oder sieben brot rezepte
ich esse ich nur alle auch ich kann aber
nicht mehr ist irgendwann liegt hier
aber der vorteil von dem selbst
gemachten brot ist einfach es bleibt ja
auch lange haltbar das heißt wir können
die nächsten zehn tage vor dessen ja
natürlich schlimm es auch wieder nicht
immer toll das ist doch kräftig und
intensiv im geschmack und ihr habt
gesehen es ist gar nicht so schwierig
dieses büro zuzubereiten vor allem finde
ich es mit dem laptop richtig schön weil
man hat da einfach diese typische brot
form finde ich und trocken brot ist
wirklich schwierig eigentlich in form zu
bekommen
aber wir haben das ganze mit dem
frühstück gemacht dadurch wurde der teig
schön formbar
der steht nicht grüßt nicht frühstück
und so ich hab das berühmte stück
angesetzt da ja ich bin total von nebel
und von dem ganzen vor lauter brot ja
wir machen jetzt gleich noch ein paar
fotos für unseren blog und für instagram
und facebook und falls ihr das rezept
gerne nachmachen möchte dann schaut auf
meinem blog auf sallys blog.de vorbei da
steht noch mal alles ganz genau worauf
es packen und machte im anschnitt
einfach das boot so hinstellen damit es
nicht an trocknet den habe ich jetzt
schon zum fünften mal gibt es also viel
spaß beim backen und bis zum nächsten
mal schießt sich auf rot-rot-grün
schicken okay aber dann muss aber zu
holen
[Musik]